last week we asked you on twitter if
portuguese star striker Cristiano
Ronaldo should really be earning 45
million euros a year and the verdicts
out eighteen percent believe he's worth
every cent seventy-three percent say no
way that would be including me nine
percent couldn't care less now what do
you think follow us on Twitter and give
us your take joining me in the studio
now is gido chef meister he is the CEO
of the sport management academy in
beloit gear thanks for being with us now
to start things off what do you think is
Ronaldo worth 45 million a year yes is
yeah why is that because you can refund
the payment easily when in terms of star
items you can set on other things like
merchandise and so forth so I don't know
the numbers precisely how much they get
back in terms of money but i'm quite
sure he's worth the money yes so he
seems a good business asset I think so
yeah Real Madrid yeah all right now a
recent TV rights deal gives 2.3 billion
euros to clubs in the English Premier
League is there really that much money
to be earned with the sport obviously
because it's the TV stations is the
media companies willing to pay that
amount of money and they have to refund
the money as well and it seems to me
that they see the chance to refund that
payments so there must be enough
opportunity to get the money back yeah
what does this sort of money due to the
sport to the perception of the sport um
to the person i would say what you can
see immediately is that usually the
wages of the players get higher and
higher by that so a lot of money is
usually put into Young's young talents
and players as well so that changes
tremendously the business I would say
because it's if you compare that with
German figures it's quite a high amount
of money the the clubs have in Great
Britain yeah now you mention Germany
yeah Bayern Munich has more money than
any other team in the Bundesliga at in a
league and is dominating a league that
used to be much more competitive now
does too much money lead to an uneven
playing field here I think so yes
actually because what we can observe
from research in that field is
we are talking about something like
competitive balance so how balance is
the league and we know that more or less
money is able to score in the end of the
day so if clubs have more money and the
others have less money so if we have if
it goes apart from each other usually we
observe something that says it's not
that interesting anymore yeah and just
bravely do you think smaller clubs
should get financial help in order to
keep things more interesting and quite
sure it is in the interest of the league
and of the club's themselves that the
the league itself is competitive is
strong because it is interesting if the
league itself is strong so if we have
interesting matches going on that makes
it even more attractive to watch the
games so they should all be interested
in having at least a similar strength
and one should win in the end all right
we'll see if that will happen in the
Bundesliga anytime soon gido shaft
meister we'll talk some more in a bit
with me is still gido shaft maya he is
heading the sport management academy in
violet gido you yourself are counseling
young aspiring athletes what aspects of
securing their financial future do you
try to impress on them yeah I think it's
very important to keep in mind that the
career can be over very very soon it can
be health reasons whatever so and there
is a need even though they are very very
young to have an idea what comes
afterwards most of them are really
inspired they are not the ones sitting
on the or ending up as a couch potato so
they want to do something and I
definitely recommend to think about what
could be your future career how could it
look like what is the opportunity what
you can do in the future is it being a
student for a sport management program
for example or is it something else so I
definitely recommend to think about what
is my way what could I do after my
career is is over so when there's a job
after the sporting career is over how do
you do both at the same time practicing
to be a top athlete while training for
your future job that is the very very
hard thing about it because usually
athletes they have a hard job to be
successful in and you you have to have
patient and you have to put time in
however a common career lasts quite long
usually so it's not about one or two
years usually and you have a lot of art
Unity's to for example to get in a
part-time study program to do that
besides your job and there are many
offers that and coming they were coming
during the last years to bring athletes
in the classroom I was just teaching one
of these athletes two weeks ago and so
they are picking single classes out of a
curriculum and after a longer period of
time then they're going to finish the
study program the do clubs need to get
more involved when it comes to securing
a life after football I think clubs need
the openness to make it possible for the
players for example sometimes to attend
things like classrooms or whatever or to
give the space or two to give the room
do you see that happening yeah I see
that more and more happening actually
okay and lastly I can't let you go
obviously without your bet who's gonna
win the European Championship the best
team the best oh come on for sure I have
a heart and I hope it's gonna be germany
but i'm i'm not sure so the best who's
gonna win yeah my heart is German so
that's leader chef master thank you very
much